okay so many of you aware that it is not
just got not op de client is a
possibility to explain donald trumps
bizarre behavior by increasing the
explanation get more more
action is en capten min you for better
silk of use
we've seen from  upper and download to
very different from
depending on what clean and biologically
active is comin' on some time high
energy
sweetie rescue educated speaking quickly
corresponding met the upper face and
then the slow slow ring depressed from
barking the strobl
remark sense of the speech that sonny
jump neuron pepper and van uw from which
correspond to mori coming down from
upper face we've also some pictures of
donald trump trump tower desk start with
boxes of should've there a specific je
version of super vette [ __ ] the united
states and it is  more soon further
mechanics and kenny from legally by edit
time in the united states
if you have defects that crashes on hair and
mustache de languedoc and i have that sign
buy out
publicly t  rump off en show signs and
symptoms of en fermine be you some
examples include
sounding start up or never cease en
download app download trump gold for
the listeners
he it was possible but this coming
soon very simple is a donkey who can
just and i think if  a rebound
congestion effect get off once again en
specially when you taking
recreational my seth macy the donald
trump
box so off in a constant south coast
tapping trump in fact sound the dust
that
during the press conference with turkish
president erdogan last weekend i get a
momentarily  another effect of the
rebound and josh and f restart coming down
from the airpods
is the your sniff at which download from
this all the time
smf 10 compilation videos of cramps
speaking
and and sniffing below a beat of crisis
i'm sorry demonstrating for je  well know
trump as if peering
to him double speaking when download
sometimes it seems as though his denture
will we spiderman
the beast is on medical e  xam van da's
a weather dentures
rich guys and not to wear dentures
but i get mary k dental implants so
soon an absolute
josh hawkins the about the time out is a
symptom affra amin abou sprl rue de fer
this is where the sound like one trump  is
in vogue this house reaching codes
options and open eyes walks and mind to
possible and possibilities and finally i
s the leaders of the region for religious
israeli and palestinian jewish a crash
and a muslim jonas in the nobel
quest flashing peace
dank you godblessyou god bless  is wheel
god bless the palestinians ken god bless
you while i just let you were much do
this and again if you don't believe van
perth dentures what cried an interpreter thousand
and which people tend not to wear them
dry mouth mixen lahore sense and adjust
so help us this is another symptoms
matching pair or and families so that's all
the city we new
the new thing is that everything contacted by
and anesthesiology stewed the weekend put
theology pixels and video  of donald
trump and lesbian press conference with
the turkish president erdogan
through bright lights on the have
swimming goggles rome and in a normal
situation and people through the
relatively contracts during that
situation concreteal trump als extreme wie
die reader the people's one you look
closely at him of  this press conference
new course in a bridegroom people
sitting frogtape something is not giving
them die lead des wino
stimulans increase the concentration of
norepinephrine in the bring with capes
the people's stuck in the open position and
anesthesiology succeeded so
en rotimi when csi see someone who is
colorless
sam kan je family well you were so station
blinking alliance kon thing what we
biersack new you is here in a wide
room and you peoples and contracting of
you go to the eye doctors aires elitist
and you go up the stairs style your people
so the doctor  can
know the bins that but you can keep
go outside
i next in it very dark sunglasses with
ex  tremely jan camp robots odin about
showroom model
but this already flipping april early i wanna
hear from you
the drags speech timeout those members
people's
upper download gram sniffing and
congestion modern
rebound effect of using to much an ass
the contestants
latino sync manager of you sammy  the
cane and tweet that cap my dear
replied
the youtube clip for the facebook video
clip for ever you like and subscribe for
new videos and cascohal
this program is sponsor in part by link
is te dot com slash hook my review or
na all refurb clan box
is  amazing is an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what i do
is i took fiction box
popular nonfiction critique who your
client nonfiction weekend shifts book
in two 15 min the audiobook you get all
the most important information and
insights of something  book at you can suck
up the entire essence of the book in one
thing i've listened you
iphone of books on blank is twan reset
when a rubber girls ni  euw book de
common good i also bank
by kevin jan useful and preparing for
the soul of science miniseries dat we
produce and view free dvd van show
viewer officer usa and day free trial by
kan ik de blinkies dot com slash often
manager watch on youtube
use  the link in the video description
after free trial
if you like it you can get the full
access to thousands of condensed audio
books for at 5 bucks een man dat be
links2 dat kom for wat sla pjp
nen